Dear colleagues, if you take a seat, we can
start this session. Good afternoon to
everybody and welcome
to this AACR session entitled
"Off-the-Shelf Cell Therapies for Cancer
and Beyond." I am Franco Locatelli from Rome,
and I have the privilege to chair this session where there
will be two additional speakers, very
well-renowned in the field,
Dr. Katy Rezvani from the MD Anderson, and Dr.
David Cheng from
the Allogene Therapeutics. And in
the presentations, we will try to
address the opportunities
and the challenges associated with
different
allogeneic CAR cell platform, including the
conventional CAR T cells and CAR
NK cell. And I have the
privilege to start with the first presentation
entitled "Allogeneic CAR Cells:
Are They the New Black?"
Before addressing the topic,
let me share for some seconds my
disclosures. In particular, in the
next minutes, I will
address with you some examples of
use allogeneic CAR T cells without any
manipulation
that we have developed in Rome, while
Dr. Rezvani will address the use of
off-the-shelf allogeneic CAR NK
cells. And finally, Dr. Cheng
will mainly focus his presentation on
strategies to avoid the rejection of
the CAR T.
So allogeneic CAR T cells
offer some obstacles, but also opportunities
and advantages, because if there is no
discussion that the use of CAR T cell have
revolutionized the treatment landscape for
B-cell malignancies and multiple myeloma,
there is still room to improve. And one of the
reason
for the treatment failure in these patients is
related
to the poor autologous T cell function.
So using allogeneic CAR T
offer the obstacle that
these effector cells can mediate the
development of GvHD,
and the allogeneic CAR T cell
can be rejected by the
recipient
immune responses mediated by either T
lymphocytes or NK cells, or both.
This said, however, the great advantage
of the approach is that of potentially
using a CAR T cell product associated
with a better T cell fitness to minimize the
risk, at least in the context of
leukemia, of inadvertent leukemia cell
transduction. As I already
mentioned, we can use platforms other than
the conventional T lymphocytes,
and we may have the opportunity to knock
down TCR and HLA molecules
for avoiding GvHD and
graft rejection, respectively. And just to
mention one of the
outstanding papers published by the
Ghosh group in London, in particular by Robert
Kayser, knocking down these two molecules together with
CD52 resulted into
impressive results in children
and young adults with T-cell acute
lymphoblastic leukemia. In addition
to all these potential advantages, if you
concentrate in the lower part of this cartoon,
you can realize that being
obtained by healthy donor, the
lymphocytes are not exposed to the immune
suppressive effect displayed by
monocytes and myeloid-derived suppressor cells,
not to talk
the regulatory T lymphocytes that can jeopardize
the response. And as I
anticipated, let me
shareFor example,
of years of allogeneic CAR cells that
we have developed in Rome, starting from
the first one
that we published some years ago in
Blood,
taking advantage of a collaboration with Miltenyi
using their CAR construct for
manipulating a fresh leukapheresis and
infusing fresh
CAR T lymphocytes. In particular, I
am glad to share with you the updated analysis
of a patient treated on a
hospital exemption basis. We initially published
in Blood that 13 children, now they are
19. And as you can appreciate in this
cartoon,
these patients had very poor risk
characteristics, including
genetic molecular abnormalities known to
predict a poor outcome or
very early first relapse. And let me
draw your attention on the fact that in a quarter of
cases, the donor was an HLA
haploidentical relative. And we infuse up
to three million of CAR
T per kg. Indeed, this was the dose
employed in the majority of patients.
And the reason for adopting this approach
was based on the fact that
most patients treated with this
strategy were lymphopenic,
although there were also four patients who had
previously failed
an autologous product. And you can
appreciate in this slide that the safety profile
was more than acceptable. We didn't record
any Grade 3 to 4 ICAN, and only one case
of
Grade 3 to 4 CRS, and there were only
two patients who developed acute
GVHD, both transplanted from a
nine out of ten HLA-matched unrelated volunteer,
clearly indicating that the use of even an
HLA haploidentical donor was not associated
with the development of GVHD. And both these
cases were rescued by steroids
and JAK1/2 inhibitors.
All the patients had a complete response with
MRD negativity in the bone marrow, as well as all
patients with
CNS involvement have responded.
Out of the other six patients with an
involvement of an extramedullary site,
responded with only one exception, and the
three-year probability of
progression-free survival is 42%,
nine patients having experienced a further
recurrence, and two cases with a
CD19 negative
leukemia blast. And we consider that
this data promising enough to
activate a formal clinical trial that
is recruiting in our center.
And this slide summarizes the
main inclusion criteria. Namely,
patients must have had a relapse
after allogeneic transplant or a
relapse/refractory disease
with failure of both frontline and two
rescue strategies. Importantly and
notably, patients must be ineligible for the
commercially available autologous CD19-directed
CAR T-cell, or have relapsed within
six months after transplant because
there are data published by the German pediatric
group clearly showing that the outcome of these kids
is dismal, or have a
very low lymphocyte count or a very
high blast contamination, potentially exposing the patient
to the risk of either manufacturing failure
or inadvertent transduction of leukemia cells.
And we stratify the patients according to
the HLA identity and the donor recipient
pair. In particular, Cohort one included
patients treated with a CAR T-cell
manufactured from an HLA-identical sibling or an
unrelated donor. Testing to this level,
namely three million and five million of
CAR T-cell per kg. While
in the Haplo cohort, we
tested lower cell dose, namely
one and three million of CAR T
per kg. All these patients received the
classical conventional lymph depletion therapy,
and we have already completed enrollment
for the Cohort
A, and
we are completing that of Cohort B.
As you can appreciate in this cartoon, all
patients but one had previously failed
blinatumomab, and half of the
patients had already failed
TISA cells. Many of the kids
had poor risk abnormalities,
including KMT2A rearrangement, Ikaros
plus, or
deletion or mutation of TP53.
And remarkably, in the Cohort A, three
patients had not previously received a
transplant.Again, we confirm a very
good safety profile with only one
case of Grade 2 acute
GvHD, no case of Grade 3 to 4 acute
GvHD. And as for the cohort
A, the recommended dose is five million of CAR-T per
kg.
And you can appreciate in this cartoon that there
was a very good expansion of the allogeneic CAR-T
in peripheral blood, with no difference
between the two cohorts. And looking
at the response, all the patients obtain
an
MRD negative complete remission in the bone marrow.
There was only one patient who didn't get a
complete response for bone
lesions. And looking at the
outcome, you can appreciate that
four out of the six patients of cohort A and
three out of the four for cohort B are alive
and disease-free.
So the main take home messages are
summarized in this cartoon.
What I'd like to highlight is
that
there was no unacceptable risk of acute
GvHD despite the fact that we use
unmanipulated cells, and this is an
observation that should be considered
when we address the use of genetically
modified cells to avoid the risk of
GvHD. The second model that I'd like to
discuss with you is that of T-ALL,
in which we invested on the use of
CD7 targeting CAR-T
because, as you know very well, there is no
leukemia-specific antigen. And
these CD7 CAR-T cells
are manufacturing using a CAR construct
that includes a protein expression blocker.
It's the fruit of a collaboration with Dario Campana and the
colleagues of the National University of Singapore, and
the approach is a great
opportunity not only for the T-ALL kids, but
also for those 15% of AML
patients whose leukemia blast express CD7.
And we already obtained evidence
in a study published
two years ago together with the colleagues of
NUS, that
the approach is valid, and we are
recruiting patients. We have already
completed the phase one portion of the trial,
and
also 12 patients have been enrolled in the phase
two portion. However, there are patients in
whom it's not possible to generate
the CAR-T cells. And let me share with you
two cases. One was a child initially
treated by our French colleague, and the other one
was treated here in the US. They were referred
to us to be offered the CD7
CAR-T cells.
But unfortunately, these patients either
had a very low CD3+ cell
count or a very high
peripheral blast contamination.
So they were not eligible to be treated
with the autologous product.
And thus, we decided to generate the
CAR-T cells from either the father or the
mother in the two patients.
And you can appreciate in this cartoon that after
the infusion, the HLA identical
CAR-T cells expanded over time. They cause
a complete depletion of CD7 positive cells
in peripheral blood. But more
importantly, at four weeks after the infusion,
there was a complete MRD
negativity, and these patients were then
consolidated with an allograft, and the first one
is now in remission at around two years
after transplantation, while the second one
relapsed with CD7 negative leukemia
cells. And none of these two patients
experienced GvHD, again, showing
in a different context that the
allogeneic CAR-T cell can be a valuable option
if you don't have the possibility to use the classical
autologous product. The third model that
I'd like to discuss with you is neuroblastoma.
You know that we invested on third generation
CAR-T targeting GD2 with
a-CIPIT is which included into the study,
and we initially published the results on
27 patients, showing
a good overall response, in particular in patients
with a limited tumor burden. And we
recently updated this cohort
that now includes
54 patients, 35 treated in the
clinical trial and 19 offered the CAR
T in an hospital exemption setting.
And you can appreciate that in patient treated
with CAR T cells at the
recommended dose and in the presence of a low tumor
burden, the five-year EFS overcome
50%. But there were two
main findings deriving from this second study, and
I'd like to draw your attention on the
fact that patient treated with CAR T cell
manufactured using lymphocytes collected at
diagnosis had a better outcome, and this
finding suggesting or highlighting once again the
importance of the lymphocyte
fitness. So the question was if we
can imagine to use the CAR T cell source in a
solid tumor, and in particular, we offered the
approach either to children with a mild
lymphopenia or already failing
the autologous CAR T cells. We
treated five patients, and two of them
reach a complete CR with
clearance of the MIBG lesions
at the scan. And if you compare,
for example, these two patients, you
immediately realize that in one
of them, there was a better expansion of
the CAR T in comparison to the
previous autologous infusion. While in the other one,
there was no difference, suggesting that there was no
sensitization against the CAR construct.
And when we analyze the transcriptomic
level profiling the cells, we didn't
see any difference in terms of drug product, while
in the cells retrieved at the peak of expansion,
there was an enrichment in the allo
product of gene that are
related to T cell proliferation, immune synapses,
and cell polarity, while in the autologous product,
there was a positive regulation of
autophagy and genes involved in glycolysis and
nucleotide metabolism. Once again,
pointing out towards a better function of allogeneic
cells. Just one word, because the topic
will be extensively discussed by Dr.
Raxwaney on allogeneic CAR NK cells.
We decided to invest on AML, in
particular on allogeneic CAR NK cells
targeting CD123. We demonstrated the
in vitro an excellent activity comparable to that
of the conventional CAR T cells, which was
confirmed also in the animal model
with a more favorable toxicity profile in
terms of
mitigation of the xenograft reaction
with the allogeneic CAR NK cells. And when we
look at the damage on the endothelial
cells, it became very clear that the allogeneic
CAR NK cells were associated with less
damage. So all in all, I think that there
is now room for
investing on the allogeneic CAR products, and
you will have further demonstration from these two
subsequent talks. Let me close my presentation
thanking all the people working with me, and a
particular mention to Concetta Quintarelli
and Biagio De Angelis, and I'd like to thank also
the international collaborators, the charities, and the
institution which invested on
our preclinical and clinical
programs. Thank you.
So if there is one burning question,
and then we can move with the other presenters.
You have time, Franco. You know you'll have time until 1:00.
Okay.
Okay. So, thank you for a great talk.
I have a question regarding the lymphodepletion and also host cell recovery.
So one of your slides said you dosed one gram per square meter
cyclophosphamide, I think for CD19
trial. And then how did you
select the dose of lymphodepletion?
Did you have any consideration for treating patients?
And another question is, did you see any difference in terms of
kinetics or cell type composition in the host cell recovery in
children compared with adult patients?
So thanks for both questions. We decided since the very
beginning to invest on a higher dose of
cyclophosphamide, exactly for reducing the
risk of graft rejection and promoting a better
homeostatic expansion.
The dose of cyclophosphamide
was tolerated very well. And concerning
the second question, we are a pediatric institution,
mainly dealing with kids, as the number
of adults that we treated is too low to draw
any firm conclusion.
So it's my pleasure and privilege to introduce
Cathy Rezvani, who is an
outstanding expert in the field of
CAR cells and in particular of CAR NK
cell. Please, Cathy.
Thank you.
Great.
Thank you very much, Franco. Hello, everyone.
It's great to
be here, and I'm grateful to the organizing committee for
giving us this opportunity. These are my disclosure slides.
So natural killer cells are part of our innate immune system, are particularly
attractive for allogeneic cell therapy because in the allogeneic setting,
they don't cause graft versus host disease.
Killing is mediated through multiple
innate receptors, endogenous receptors through which NK cells can
recognize
abnormal cells, such as cancer cells, and of course, you add your CAR,
now you have multiple mechanisms of killing.
And NK cells are also a mediator of antibody-dependent cellular
cytotoxicity through the CD16 receptor, and the reason
why many monoclonal antibodies we use in the clinic actually work.
They have a very attractive safety profile in that cases of
CRS and ICANS are not as common after CAR NK
cells.
Although there are certainly some questions around
NK cell therapies in that they have a limited lifespan.
NK cells, in the absence of cytokine support, only have a one to
two-week lifespan, and it's still unclear what's the best starting population
for manufacturing. And that's why multiple different groups are looking at
different strategies, including peripheral blood, obviously, NK cell
lines, induced pluripotent stem cells.
We work with cord blood, partly because at MD Anderson, we have our own
cord blood bank, which was established by my colleague and good friend, Dr.
Spall. And we've developed the
SOPs to generate
50 to 100-plus doses of CAR NK cells from one cord
blood unit in a two-week manufacturing process at a cost of only
a few hundred dollars or a couple of thousand dollars to us, which we
can then biobank and use to
support multiple different trials, asking different questions.
So a few years ago now, we started a
phase one first-in-human trial where we took cord blood NK
cells, then we engineered them with this viral vector that was shared with us by
Pietro Dotti when he was at Baylor College of Medicine.
And this was an interleukin-15 armored CAR,
IL-15 supporting the proliferation of the NK cells, and it also incorporated
a safety switch. So we published the data on the phase
one and phase two
elements of this trial,
and we show a very excellent safety profile, very promising
activity, but also something that was very interesting to us, an
observation that we made was that the quality of the umbilical
cord blood unit that we had used for manufacturing of our CAR NK
cells was a very important determinant of response.
In that if we use CAR NK cells from cord blood units that were frozen
within 24 hours of collection and with a nucleated red blood count
of 80 million, our one-year progression free survival was actually
70% with a one-year overall survival of 95%.
Patients who received CAR NK cells from cord blood units frozen
after 24 hours of collection and with a higher nucleated red blood
count, as you can see, had a dismal outcome.
And then we validated this in
multiple mouse models. We looked at the transcriptomic profile and
epigenomic profile, and we really demonstrated that
this starting population was very important.
And so since then, we've also done a lot of studies comparing NK
cells from different sources. Specifically, and this is a collaboration with
Ken Chan and work that is being led by Vaku Mohenji and Merve Dede,
where we looked at NK cells that were isolated from cord blood
versus those from peripheral blood and versus
developmental NK from a published
single-cell data from fetal tissue.
And what we found was that cord blood NK cells
seem
to sit somewhere between developmental and peripheral blood NK cells.
They share cytotoxicity programs very similar to peripheral
blood, but also maintain some of the
developmental features of tissue residency
as well as stemness, similar to fetal NK.
And so perhaps it's through this intermediate state that is at least
partly supporting the encouraging data that we're seeing with
cord blood NK cells.So then we
decided to take our approach to target another antigen called
CD70, which is expressed on many different cancer types, including both
hematologic malignancies and solid tumors.
The preclinical work on the CAR design and optimization and
selection of the optimal co-stimulatory molecule was published in Cancer
Discovery a couple of years ago by Sunil Acharya, and we picked the
best CAR, and we translated that to the clinic, and this was
a CAR that had the extracellular domain of the human CD27
receptor, which is the natural receptor for CD70.
Co-stimulation was through CD28, of course, interleukin-15,
and the safety switch. So from two umbilical cord blood units,
starting from optimal cord blood based on the criteria that I mentioned to
you, we manufactured 250 patient doses at an average
cost of $600. And so we started a dose escalation
study
as a basket study in hematologic malignancies with a
starting cell dose of a flat dose of eight million.
And just to put that into context, usually with autologous CAR T cells,
a dose of 100 to 200 million cells are
infused. So this is a case of a young man that we treated.
It was the eighth relapse of his disease, had received two prior
transplants, and yet he received the eight million NK dose.
You can see he had very extensive disease.
Day 30, day 60 post-infusion, he goes into complete
remission, and we can see his LDH levels as a
biomarker of his tumor normalize within two weeks.
Now I'd like to also highlight the case of another patient.
This is a patient with a primary refractory diffuse large B-cell
lymphoma, fifth relapse of his disease.
In this particular patient, CAR T-cell manufacturing had failed because he was so
lymphopenic.
And
basically, we gave him the cells. He goes into complete remission.
He's 18 months out. He's still in CR, and he had mediastinal disease that
you can see disappeared.
But the reason I want to highlight this is that the question always is asked
around CAR NK cells is that do they proliferate and do they persist?
And I think this example really shows that they do.
So using HLA antibodies directed against the
HLA mismatch between the donor NK cells and the recipient,
we could follow expansion of the
donor CAR NK cells that were HLA-A3 positive in an
HLA-A3-negative recipient. And you can see that
six months following infusion, we can still detect these CAR NK
cells in the peripheral blood of the patient.
And this shows the copy
numbers of the CAR transgene in the peripheral blood of the patient, where you can
see really between day three and day 14, there is a massive expansion of
these cells, following by a contraction, as expected of an
antigen-driven response. And then when we tested the activity of
these cells in vitro, you can see that they can kill
CD70-positive
Raji tumor cells very nicely, very similar to the
infusion product.
And then performing single-cell RNA sequencing on the peripheral blood
from this patient, you can really see that the kinetic
of the CAR NK expansion is very
dynamic. And so initially, we see expansion of this
first clone, this clone zero, very early on, and then this
contracts, followed by then emergence of this clone four that
then contributes to the long-term persisting clone.
And
this clone four is transcriptionally
very different to clone zero, suggesting that different
transcriptional programs are dictating the initial response,
the initial proliferation versus the persistence of the cells.
So in this particular CD70 CAR NK trial, the patients were
very heavily pretreated. They'd received a median of eight prior lines of
treatment, and actually,
36% of them had received 10 or more prior lines of
therapy. So very heavily pretreated.
So in view of that and in view of the very excellent safety
data and efficacy and promising
efficacy results, we went to FDA, and we've
received approval for a trial with CD70 CAR NK cells in
patients with lymphoid malignancies
after first or second line of
treatment. And also now we're planning a multicenter study
with our partner hospitals across the United
States.
We've also
taken an approach and taken our CAR NK cells to
treat and target T-cell malignancies.
You heard from Franco
some of the challenges with targeting T-cell
malignancies with CAR T cells in that the antigen is often
shared between healthy T cells and the
tumorous T cells, and as a result of that, that results in
friticide during manufacturing and the risk of
tumor contamination in the infusion product.
So we decided to target a molecule, CD5, that is expressed
on many T-cell malignancies and actually also on some
B-cell malignancies, including mantle cell lymphoma and chronic lymphocytic
leukemia, but absent on NK cells. So again, we did
all the preclinical work in terms of optimizing the CAR design, picking the
right co-stimulatory molecule, et cetera, and then we
picked a design that again included
CD28 co-stimulation, the cytokine IL-15, our
safety switch, and then we took a banked optimal cord
blood unit, expanded the cells, and then we made a
biobank of these. And this is a trial led by my colleague, Dr.
Hosing, dose escalation study. And we decided to put our focus on
a type of leukemia called T-cell prolymphocytic leukemia.
It's a rare
T-cell malignancy, but it has a dismal outcome.
And over the last two decades, really, there hasn't been any improvement
in the outcome of these patients, as you can see from this recent
publication.And so we're still at dose
level one, and I just wanted to share some of these preliminary data with you.
We've treated four patients with TPLAL.
You can see they were all heavily pre-treated, and three of those
patients have gone into complete remission.
And in these flow plots, you can see how
the emergence of our donor CAR NK
cells correlates with disappearance of these TPLAL
cells. Isolating the NK cells from the peripheral blood of the
patients, again, we can see that they are just as good as the infusion
product in clearing
the CD5 positive leukemia cells. So they're
maintaining their functionality.
So then, of course, all of these require CAR engineering,
et cetera. So we asked this question: what if we harness that
CD16 receptor that is important for mediating
antibody-dependent cellular cytotoxicity and instead
redirect the specificity of NK cells by combining them with
biologic, combining them with antibodies?
So the preclinical work for this approach was led by Lucila
Kerbai, which was a postdoc in my lab.
And now Lucila is a faculty member
in São Paulo, at São Paulo
University
in Brazil. But what she showed is that if we combine
our NK cells with a bispecific NK cell engager called
AFM13, that binds to CD16 on the one
hand and CD30 on the other hand, we can redirect the
specificity of NK cells towards this target.
And I should hasten to add that the AFM13 as a single agent had been
tested in the clinic previously by the company who developed
this
antibody,
and the name of the company was Affimed.
And basically, they had reported a 16% overall response rate
with no complete remissions. So then we took this approach to the
clinic of combining our NK cells with
AFM13. This was work led by Dr. Yago Nieto.
And we published the data recently in 42 patients with Hodgkin lymphoma,
very heavily pre-treated, seven prior lines of therapy.
They'd all had previous CD30 targeting antibodies.
Many of them had had a transplant. They all had progressive disease.
No patient received bridging therapy.
This is an example of before and after, and our response rates were
really pretty astounding in that we saw an overall response rate of
greater than 90% with two-thirds of patients going into complete remission.
However,
in the absence of a
transplant consolidation, many of these patients who'd
achieved a response went on to progress.
And the reason for that was, as one would expect
of the
pharmacokinetic of non-engineered NK cells, these
cells only persisted for a week or two weeks following infusion.
And just because this is of course very different to what we saw with our
CAR design, where the cells were, we observed them to
persist for months, if not
one or two years following infusion.
But I think this study really showed to us the power of
combining biologics with
healthy
NK cells from a good source of
adoptive cell therapy. And this then led us to come up with this
idea
of rather than engineering
a CAR for every specific target, for every specific
disease, what we could actually do is first
endow NK cells with the ability to be combined
with
engagers, with antibodies. So what we did was we
engineered our NK cells to express CD3.
And this allowed then our NK cells to be
combined with T cell engagers. We engineered the
NK cells also to express high-affinity CD16, which then would allow us
to combine them with select monoclonal antibodies
and
also ADCs. We also engineered the NK cells to express
invariant TCR, which then now allows them to
recognize glycolipids presented in the context of
CD1d.
They still express their endogenous receptors, and then they can also
secrete interleukin-15 for persistence.
And in vitro, we demonstrated that these
engineered NK cells that we call Plurilink, when coupled with
EGFR-targeting antibodies, they can eradicate the tumor cells very
nicely. Similarly, with T cell engagers such as
blinatumomab, we saw very nice clearance.
We could also combine them with certain ADCs that
still have an intact IgG, such as brentuximab, and
also with talatuzumab, which targets the DLL3, so
bispecific T cell engager. And actually, in vivo in this mouse model,
you can see that our Plurilink
NK cells with a bispecific T cell engager against
BCMA do actually even better than BCMA CAR NK
cells. So now we've taken this approach to the clinic, and we have
now a clinical trial with these
Plurilink cells combined
with epcor, which is a bispecific T cell engager against
CD20, and tafasitamab which is a
monoclonal antibody targeting CD19 for a dual
targeting approach for lymphoid malignancies led by Dr. Nieto.
And then we also have a second trial of our Plurilink cells plus
tafasitamab targeting CD19 in autoimmune disorders, including
lupus and scleroderma, in collaboration with Dr.
Osasya at UT Health and Dr. Barrera at Baylor
College of Medicine, led by Dr. Hosing at our
center.We are also taking our
approach of adoptive NK cell therapy to targeting
solid tumors. However, here, in addition to engineering the cells
for tumor targeting, we also need to engineer them to
enhance their penetration,
and also to
make them more resistant to the immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment.
CAR T cells have been tested for glioblastoma with local regional
delivery, and interesting, certainly responses
have been observed, but these have been limited by neurotoxicity
and also modest progression-free survival.
So really, there's a need for safer and more effective
therapies in this setting.
So a few years ago, we demonstrated that NK cells are
capable of killing glioblastoma cancer stem cells, but
that TGF-beta is a very important mechanism of
immunosuppression. And then this led us to develop this clinical trial
where using CRISPR gene editing, we deleted the TGF-beta
receptor II gene and also the glucocorticoid receptor gene
to allow the concurrent administration of steroids.
And this is a trial led by my colleague, Dr.
Sharpé Weathers, where patients receive these double knockout cord
blood NK cells intratumorally. There is no cytokine engineering,
so patients receive eight infusions of these, and
with a starting dose of 20 million cells.
We've now treated six patients at dose level one.
All of these patients had refractory disease.
Four out of six patients have achieved stable disease.
This last patient has just received his eighth dose of the
cells, and it's been very well tolerated.
In four patients, we had the opportunity to look at the
tumor before and after giving our NK cells,
and we could demonstrate infiltration
of our
donor NK cells in the tumor tissue, as you can see here, and these
NK cells had an activated transcriptomic
profile. But very interestingly, it appears that our NK cells
also
modulate the myeloid microenvironment in that we
saw a reduction in CD163 positive, IBA
positive macrophage myeloid cells post-infusion,
and a shift from M2 to M1-like
myeloid cells. And these myeloid cells had higher expression
of
OXPHOS-related genes, as well as class one
MHC antigen presentation and activation.
And also very interestingly, we showed that
following NK cells, there was greater infiltration by both
CD8 and CD4 T cells in the tumor
microenvironment, and these have, again, a signature
of antigen receptor signaling and T cell activation.
So really, these NK cells seem to be modulating the immune
microenvironment. So then we ask, can we further enhance
the activity of our NK cells against glioblastoma by
cytokine engineering? And this is work that was led by Myra Shanley in the group,
where she demonstrated that if we engineer NK cells with
interleukin-21, this can really enhance the activity of
our NK cells against glioblastoma, and this was published last
year. But Myra showed that IL-21 is superior to
IL-15 and results in better mitochondrial function as well as
polyfunctionality of these cells.
And this was mediated through induction of CBPD, and you can see
here one injection of these IL-21 NK cells to these mice
can cure them, whereas IL-15 can't.
So based on that, now we've developed a next generation CAR design
where the vector, there's a dual targeting of IL-13 receptor,
alpha and EGFR V3, together with IL-21 armoring
and the safety switch. And in addition, we've also incorporated double
knockout targeting TGF-beta receptor II and the NR3C1
gene.
And you can see here, again, one injection can cure the animals in an orthotopic
model. And so now we've taken this to the clinic.
In the interest of time, I'm going to skip all the IND-enabling
studies that we had to do. But just to show that from one
cord blood unit, we've manufactured 70 patient doses with an
excellent CAR transduction efficiency and dual knockout efficiency.
This was work done by Mariam Imari in our group, and with an average cost of
only a couple of thousand dollars.
And so we've just received approval from FDA to move forward with a
clinical trial that will be led by Dr. Ene together with Dr.
Lang in our
neurosurgical department. And here we will be
testing the best route of delivery.
Patients will be randomized to receiving either intratumoral,
intraventricular, or intra-arterial injections of the cells.
So we'll test both safety and efficacy.
And finally, we also have a very
expansive discovery platform that was established by Dr.
Bidesh Das in the group, and where we perform
genome-wide CRISPR screen on primary human NK cells and CAR
NK cells, where they're being exposed to
stimuli that simulate an immunosuppressive tumor
microenvironment, including repeated tumor challenge
and immunosuppressive molecules to
identify negative regulators of
NK cell function. And this work was recently published.
So this basically summarizes our upcoming
pipeline for 2026, where we are
combining NK cell engineering, CAR engineering, and T cell
engineering with CRISPR gene editing, and also with
combination with radiation and oncolytic viruses, et cetera.
IND-enabling studies on all of these are done, and we're very hopeful that in Q2,
Q3 of 2026, we can move forward with these.
This is really an incredible collaboration across the institution with
trials that are being led by these amazing clinicians at
MD Anderson across pretty much all of
our departments. With that, I'd like to thank my amazing team,
our funding agencies, our GMP facility, our cord blood bank,
and most importantly, our patients and their families.
And thank you very much for your attention.
There is time for a couple of questions before the
final discussion on all three presentations.
Please.
A couple of questions, Katie. First one, in your
CD3-enabled NK cells, did you consider adding
IL-15 to increase the persistence like in the other trials?
Yes. Sorry, I went over it very quickly.
IL-15 is part of the vector. Absolutely.
There's CD3 high affinity, CD16 invariant TCR, and
IL-15.
And secondly, across trials, how much
HLA matching did you do, and did you see a
correlation between persistence and response and the degree of
match?
We don't do any HLA matching, so the donors are
selected without that. At the moment, we don't see a really
significant effect of HLA matching or not
matching, basically-
Thank you
... in terms of persistence.
Thank you, Katie. That's an amazing amount of work.
Congratulations. I got a question about the cell dosing, which
is a little bit all over the place. You emphasized one trial with
just eight million was enough, and then other trials it's much more.
Is that because of underlying disease or treatment,
or what's making the difference there?
And then second quick question, you have every
whole host of malignancies except for AML,
which I didn't see on your list, which I think there's historically been a lot of
benefit.
Yeah.
So, not sure the thinking there.
Hi, Dan. Thank you for those questions.
So we are not seeing necessarily a dose effect because we see those
amazing proliferations.
And because every
trial is designed by a different
PI, our starting dose can be any-- We try to
start with a starting dose of 40 million,
and then it depends on the FDA reviewer that we get.
Sometimes they force us to go one log down, which is why some of the trials start
with eight million. But really, it's starting with 40 million and going
up by half a log, and that's the recommendation by the FDA.
AML, yes, we do have two trials with AML.
I didn't have time to go through them.
There's one trial that is being led by Dr.
Nick Short with TGF-beta receptor II knockout CD70
targeting CAR NK cells. Early days.
We have seen
responses in patients, which is encouraging, but we don't know
anything about persistence of those responses.
And we also have a second trial with TCR NK cells
targeting PREM. Again, early
days. Still dose level one. We've seen one or two patients
respond. So we'll see as we go up the dose what we would observe.
Thank you.
Last question. Very brief and very rapid
answer.
Yeah, thank you. Very impressive works.
So I have one question about the in vivo persistence of the allogeneic CAR NK
cells. So your data about the CD70 targeting CAR NK
show very impressive in vivo persistence.
So I'm wondering whether you have ever seen the similar trends for other
CAR. The reason why I'm asking, because people have already reported
like alloreactive T cells upregulate CD70, and targeting the
CD70 may induce the elimination of the
alloreactive T cells and enhance the allogeneic CAR
cells.
Yeah.
So yeah, I'm wondering whether the amazing in
vivo persistence, is IL-15 induce the persistence or
the CD17 targeting CAR induce the
persistence of the-
So you definitely need the IL-15, and we've also observed that
with our CD5 CAR NK program because it also obviously targets the T
cells of the recipient.
I see. Thank you.
Thank you.
So the third and last speaker, but certainly not the
least one, is Dr. Cheng from
Allogene Therapeutics in San Francisco.
And
at the end of his presentation, we will
have,
in addition to the questions specific for him,
a general discussion. Thank you.
Yeah.
First of all, thank you very much for inviting me for this excellent session.
I'm going to follow the discussion more towards
how to translate the science to make it practical as we
advance the allogeneic cell therapy into the clinics.
So my disclosure, and really the topics that I would like
to cover, why does allogeneic CAR T?
My discussion will be somewhat focused on the T cell-based allogeneic cell
therapy, unlike the NK cells, but really the fundamental question
of why the allogeneic and how the field has
progressed over the last several years to overcome some of the key
barriers to make the allogeneic CAR T work.
So when you think about
from 30,000 feet up,
CAR T therapy is so unique to any
other therapy that came before that in several different ways.
But probably, one that we all remember is the
remarkable durability,
and the durability is coming with a one-time therapy.
I've been in the oncology field for many decades, and I would
say that still there's only one therapy that brings that
kind of durability that is nearing, and
people are talking about cure with one-time infusion of the
cells.
What's also to be remembered is that as good as the
innovation that comes from the CAR T, and that's many decades of
research by luminaries in the field, other things that needs to
be addressed for the field to advance is talking about patient
accessibility and also making the CAR T
therapy scalableAs we know,
manufacturing of the CAR T is one of the barriers in terms of the
process it takes, as well as the time and the fitness of T
cells. All these things factor in.
And another thing that everybody who have been in the
field knows is that it takes time and
effort to manufacture the product.
So the way that one can think about is,
what are some of the dimensions that needs to be addressed
to make the CAR T therapy more widely available?
And first of all, it is really the efficacy, maintaining the
efficacy that comes from the autologous CAR T as you move to a
scalable
product.
Simplicity, I think the allogeneic approach naturally
brings it. It's an off-the-shelf, where the products are
available when there's a clinical demand.
And then, scalability.
Dr. Rezvani talked about CAR NK cells
being able to treat 70 to 100 patients from
each manufacturing. I think that is just the beginning, and that I
think it will continue to go up as the manufacturing process improves.
Speed, and lastly, also the safety.
We do have some unique safety issues that are associated with the CAR
T therapy, and how to mitigate those safeties, I think that's critical to
advance the field. And I would say that in the current state of
allogeneic CAR T is getting to that point that all these
five dimensions now in a reasonable time
horizon to be fully addressed.
So I'm just going to put the elephant on the table.
The biggest challenge in the allogeneic cell therapy is overcoming
the immune self, non-self recognition.
This is very fundamental immunological process
that is evolutionary
probably many, many million years.
And, we are trying to overcome that with the
evolution of different gene editing as well as gene engineering and the
manufacturing technology.
Two dimensions of this immunological process,
graft-versus-host disease.
With the understanding that came from many years of transplant
biology, everything was focused on T cell receptor.
And as it happened, at clinical experience being done with a T
cell receptor edited gene product, it essentially
takes away any risks of GvHD.
The other one, which is much of the current challenge, is how to prevent the
rejection of the allogeneic CAR T product so that it has a
reasonable time to carry out the anti-tumor effect, and
how to do that in an HLA-independent manner.
I think this is where the science has been evolving.
And recently, we are seeing many successes in that field.
So,
I'm borrowing a slide that was recently published in annual
review by Barbara Sasou. And, this really sort of
lumps up how we think about overcoming the
rejection of the allogeneic
CAR allogeneic cell therapy.
One approach is enhancing the lymphodepletion.
Usually, this is done with a cytotoxic treatment, and it comes with
the fact that the chemotherapy has other side
effects that
increases the risk of
safety issues. Generally, the higher the
chemotherapy goes, it becomes less tolerable.
Another variation is to be little bit more selective
using the antibody assisted lymphodepletion, and we'll go a little bit more
into that. And on the right side is really
making the allogeneic cells less
recognizable by the immune system, either
stealth technology, making the cells non-recognizable by the T cells
or NK cells.
And another recent approach where there's been a lot of early
promises as well as clinical success is
selectively depleting the alloreactive T cells.
I think one of the questions that came up was talking about the
CD70 being elevated in alloreactive T
cells. CD70 is one of the
antigens that gets elevated as increased
expression in the alloreactive T cells, but there are many other antigens
of similar criteria that could fit into that category.
So,
in terms of being able to
prevent the rejection and allow the cell expansion, I'm going to
illustrate two different examples here.
The first one is
using CD52 antibody
approaches. So gene engineering here
is editing out the T cell receptor and editing
out CD52 in the allogeneic CAR T product,
which allows the use of anti-CD52 antibody.
And this was tested as a CD19 allogeneic CAR T
program in patients with lymphoma, and below
is following the cell expansion using the vector copy
number. And shown here is,
with the exposure that you achieve with the alo-647 or
anti-CD52 antibody, not only you can
allow the cell expansion, but also allow the cell
expansion to persist, and this is only shown to day
28. But when you follow the patients, the
cell persistence can go up to two to three months easily.
The other approach is highlighting the product called
CD011, which is a product that Caribou is advancing.
Many different engineering was done, including editing out the
beta twoTo diminish the expression of the HLA
class I antigens,
but also introducing HLA-E to prevent
the NK-mediated killing of the allogeneic CAR T
program. Shown below is
the product being used with two different levels of lymphodepletion,
one with low and one with high. So I think all this is
pointing out the progresses that are made in this field,
either selective lymphodepletion using agents like
antibodies or a combination of gene editing and
using high-dose lymphodepletion to maintain the cell expansion and
persistence.
Next is somewhat new. These are sort of
emerging technologies. I think that this is feasible
with the availability of CRISPR
multi-gene editing approaches,
essentially trying to make the
CAR T cells evade the immune system.
And this is emerging data, but seems to have some promise coming from a
Chinese company, where the cell persistence with
a standard lymphodepletion can be measured in
a matter of months, not just in days as in the previous case.
Another one that I'm going to come back and talk a little bit more is
selective targeting alloreactive host immune cells.
So this is really leveraging the very basic biology of
how the alloreactive process occurs.
When the host or the patient's T cells recognize the target
cells, they get activated. During the activation
process, they express certain antigens.
And the question is: can we target those antigens with a CAR T
so that we can eliminate the alloreactive T cells in a
selective way before the rejection of the CAR T
product happens?
This
field was initially led by a publication
coming from Baylor College of Medicine from Malcolm Brenner's lab.
Maxim Morkin was the first author on the paper, using
4-1BB as a potential activation antigen that can be
targeted in this sort of dagger approach.
Below is a similar approach but using
CD70,
which has been recognized as one of the antigens that are
greatly upregulated in alloreactive T cells.
On the right panel is showing how they behave in the mixed lymphocyte
reaction and also examining the degree of
this antigen upregulation upon encountering the alloreactive
allogeneic CAR T cells.
Shown on the bottom is, in terms of the level of
expression as well as the duration of expression,
CD70 far behaves better as a potential
target than 4-1BB.
So this has led to the sort of really advancing this,
trying to push this field by developing CAR
T and testing them in mixed lymphocyte
reaction. Shown below is selective
depletion of CD70 expressing
the host cells while
leaving the bulk of the T cells alone.
So this is where the specificity of removing the alloreactive T
cells comes from. And then on the right panel is
using a lot more sensitive assay, using the pre-primed
alloreactive T cells in the mixed lymphocyte reaction and
demonstrating the CD CAR
can overcome the rejection that other CAR Ts can't.
So that is the science, and the
clinical validation comes from the CD70 CAR product
that went into clinical trial in relapse recurrent
renal cell carcinoma. CD70 also happens to be
one of the tumor-associated antigens,
especially in renal cell cancer. Majority of the renal
cell cancer overexpress CD70. So this was
tested in a Phase 1 dose-escalation study that also
explored different levels of
lymphodepletion.
Eventually, at the recommended Phase 2 dose of
20 million cells using the standard lymphodepletion,
the study showed a 31% objective response
rate in patients who expressed high levels of CD70 in
their renal cell cancer. Not only was the
response rate interesting, but when you follow these patients,
durability was also very compelling, with the majority of the
responding patients having durable responses exceeding
beyond 12 months.
Shown below is, on the right side,
looking at the degree of cell expansion seen in the
clinical study. So the product LO316
shown there is a Cmax as well as AUC during the
first month.
The numerical number, it's a cross-trial comparison, so
companies may have used different assays to look at the
cell persistence and the magnitude of expansion,
but usually, the assays are somewhat similar.
What's pretty evident is, as an allogeneic
CAR T product being used in an
HLA-agnostic manner with a standard
lymphodepletion, LO316 either
expanded on par with other products or exceeded the level
of expansion.Now I'm
going to change a little bit differently with what else
can be done with the allogeneic CAR T cells.
And this is really
using the clinical strategy to maximize the benefit
of the allogeneic CAR T programs. So this is a product called
ALO-501A, also known as cellmacell, that is
currently being studied in patients with large B-cell lymphoma.
Large B-cell lymphoma is curable
cancer. The standard treatment for the large B-cell
lymphoma is rituximab-based chemoimmunotherapy that's given for six
cycles. About 60% of those patients are
cured. The remaining patients have an
extremely good response, but when you follow those patients, they will
eventually recur.
So in this Alpha-3 study, which is a CT
DNA guided trial, first of its kind in the
large B-cell lymphoma, patients are being selected
based on whether they remain MRD positive or MRD
negative. And then they are randomized to either a single cycle of
cellmacell or the standard care, which is observation.
The study is using event-free survival as the primary endpoint
and have a progression-free survival as well as overall survival
as a secondary endpoint.
Recently, Allogene published an initial interim
fertility data that was focused on MRD clearance.
So before talking about that, I'm going to expand a little bit on
the benefits of using MRD in
measuring the success of treatment and also following what would
happen to the patients with MRD. This is using an
assay called Clariti that is developed by Foresight
Diagnostic, which is now a Natera company.
In a retrospective analysis in patients who have
successfully completed a frontline R-CHOP,
they were tested for the MRD or MR status.
What's shown in the red in this Kaplan-Meier curve is when you have a
detectable MRD at the end of six cycles
of R-CHOP, your likelihood of having a disease
recurrence is extremely high, and the disease
recurrence happen relatively quickly with a median time in
the range of four to six months.
Probably more striking is what happens to the MRD negative patients,
which is shown in the blue line, where these patients essentially
remain recurrence-free over 36-month timeframe
that the study followed the patients for.
So here, rather than adding the treatment
and exposing the patients who would not benefit from any
additional treatment. So these are essentially MRD negative patients
selecting on the MRD positive patients.
Another significant benefit of this approach
is
historically it has been very clear that the maximum
benefit, both from the efficacy as well as safety, comes
from when you treat the patients with a lower disease
volume.
And I would argue that going after patients who are MRD
only as evidence of disease, they will be at the lowest level
of disease. So the study design approach is
really maximizing the benefits of CAR T, going early
where you can get the best benefit, and also in patients who
needs the treatment.
So initial readout of the MRD clearance on a limited number of patients was
quite striking.
In the cellmacell treated patients, seven out of the eight
patients cleared the MRD with one cycle,
whereas in the observation arm,
there was only two patients who
cleared MRD. Whether that's a delayed response to the R-CHOP
or variability in the assay is still to be determined.
Nonetheless, the differential in the MRD between the two arm was
about 42%.
Another thing that was quite striking was the magnitude of
ctDNA reduction with
CAR T treatment. This is
doing the day 45 measurements. With a cell therapy,
you get 98% median reduction in the ctDNA,
whereas in the observation one, the trend was the other way around, where
the number went up to 26%.
So the efficacy was quite striking, but also interesting,
and this is really
playing out in the low disease volume setting.
The safety profile, we were expecting that safety
profile will be quite favorable, and that's exactly what the initial
study showed.
Without any use of tocilizumab or steroid,
there were no cases of cytokine release syndrome or
ICANS. And also when you look at the infections, they were pretty
well balanced between the two treatment.
And patients who were treated in the MRD positive
setting, none of them required hospitalization after CAR T
treatment. So it's really taking the
CAR T treatment that can be potentially
administered not just in the specialized cell centers, but in
any community-based cancer networks or cancer
centers.
Now I'm going to go to a little bit of different topic about
where the cell therapy is going. I think most people in this
room knows thatWhere the CAR T therapy started
in leukemia, it moved quickly to lymphoma, and there's a
lot of effort going into solid tumor that's ongoing.
But also another recent development is advancing the cell therapy into
non-oncology indication, namely autoimmune disorders.
The concept is very attractive. Can you deplete
the B cells or pathogenic B cells or T
cells to the level that you can reset the immune system,
thereby essentially giving patients drug-free
and treatment-free
remission from the autoimmune disorders?
The approach that we are taking is with ALO-329,
which is a dual targeting CAR that targets
CD19 B cell components as well as
CD70, which serves a dual purpose of overcoming
the rejection as well as being able to go after the
pathogenic T cells. So this program also is
taking a different approach to how we engineer,
using site-specific integration rather than using the lentivirus,
especially given the indication that we are going after.
And it's advancing as allogeneic CAR T
programs in autoimmune studies.
Going briefly about the in vitro characteristics, it behaves
exactly as we have predicted in the humanized
NSG models, where we can show a selective
depletion of B cells. And also compared to
non-CD70 containing allogeneic CAR T, we saw
persistence that last way beyond 14 days in organs such as
spleen,
which is shown on the bottom. So this study is
advancing as a dose escalation study in
four different rheumatologic indications using
simplified lymphodepletion using Cytoxan alone rather than
using cyclophosphamide and fludarabine.
And also, there's a separate arm that is testing the product
without any lymphodepletion. Study is ongoing, and we
expect to report the initial data
sometime middle of this year.
So with that, hopefully the presentation
covers
allogeneic CAR T. What are the hurdles that we have overcome,
and what are the progress that has been made in the field, not just through
the science and engineering, but also through the manufacturing
and the smart clinical design and patient selection?
And also the fact that allogeneic CAR T now is going beyond
the hematologic malignancy. Certainly, solid tumor is an active
area of research, but also non-hematologic indication is
becoming another very attractive proposition for
advancing the CAR T.
And at the end, what we are trying to do is really
democratizing cell therapy so that it can be available to
patients as they need the treatment with a low cost of goods.
So with that, obviously, there were many companies that were involved in study,
naming the few here. The team at
Allogene Therapeutics, this is the team at
our company, as well as patients and investigators who are
crucial to generate the clinical data that
informed us about how to continue to evolve and advance the
allogeneic CAR T. So with that, thank you.
Many thanks, David, for this great and very
stimulating presentation, which is now open
for question, and then we will have,
I will say 10, 12 minutes for
discussing all together the three
presentations.
I have a question.
Yes, please, Cathy.
Yeah.
David, really nice presentation. Thank you.
And your data with the MRD is very intriguing and very
interesting. So the patients who are in the control arm,
are they getting lymphodepleting chemotherapy as well?
Because--
Okay, let me take a step back. The patients after CHOP who received
the allo CAR T cells for MRD, do you give
lymphodepletion to those patients or no?
Yeah. So the patients who receive cellmeCyl, they get
standard lymphodepletion with flu cy,
despite this being allogeneic cell therapy,
whereas in the previous settings, we used flu cy plus
anti-CD52 antibody. But in this MRD-only
setting, we took out CD52, in part
because the target volume is so low.
We felt that prolonged persistence of CAR T was not critical.
And then the control group, does the control group receive
lymphodepletion without the CAR T, or they don't receive anything?
Yeah. So the control group is really the standard of care
observation.
Mm-hmm.
So-
Okay. Yeah
... they don't get anything.
Good.
Please.
Congratulations, David, on the alpha three. It's very interesting.
I'm curious if you've already had thoughts, though,
on this now increasingly
on what would happen for a patient that on relapse, there's obviously been a lot of
experience in autologous CD19 relapse and lymphoma,
but I presume the dynamics will be a little bit different here.
And is there already some sense of what you think the clinical strategy would be?
Do you just dose again, or is there antigen
negativity? Have you seen anything there?
Yeah. That's a fantastic question.
I hope that most of them do not
relapse. That's really the goal of the
studyBut if they relapse,
they're going into the second-line treatment setting.
So there are many different treatments that are available, including
otalis CAR T.
Certainly, for us, there is a consideration to re-treat the
patients as long as they remain CD19 positive.
Thank you.
David, how far from the clinical
application is the CD70
dagger approach that you mentioned?
Yeah.
So CD70 as a standard alone CAR,
it already has shown that it can overcome allo rejection
and get a kind of cell expansion that matches up
with what otalis CAR T has shown with the standard lymph depletion.
What we are trying to do is taking out that component
of CD70 to avoid the immune rejection
and then making a dual CAR with another
cancer-directed target. The first one is CD19,
CD70.
We also presented at this meeting a combination of
BCMA, CD70, and we're also working on
targets that are directed to the solid tumor.
Already tested in clinical trials?
CD19 dagger is being studied. The others are getting ready
to go into the clinics.
Please.
Yes. Thank you. Very nice talk. Very exciting data.
So I have two questions. One is about R phase three.
So I'm wondering, like without an
anti-CD52 antibody pre-treatment,
how low the cell expansion, allo CAR T cell
expansion, CD19 allo CAR T expansion in patient, how low
that can persist,
and how it correlated with MRD clearance
or reduction? So another question, it's about you have
two asset, right? One is the CD19,
CD70. Another one is the CD70. I know it's
target a different indication, but I'm just curious,
if dual target like a CD90, CD70,
I mean the CK, the cell expansion difference between
dual CAR and a single CAR.
If dual CAR because add the
vector size will be bigger, right?
Will add more selection pressure or CAR T
cells. I'm just wondering if dual CAR might
have lower cell expansion in patient compared
to single CAR.
Okay. So, the first question, when it comes to
CD52 antibody,
in the earlier days when we were studying
in a semester cell in relapse refractory setting, we used
standard lymph depletion plus CD52 antibody.
In the MRD study, we took our CD52 antibody
altogether. To answer the question, when you have the
CD52 antibody, the main advantage that you get is the
length of CAR T persistence.
Cell expansion in terms of peak improves, but it's really the
cell
being present beyond 28 days, that was really the critical
thing, and we felt that was important in the relapse
recurrent setting.
The second question on CD19, CD70, I can
tell you in in vitro experiment, this
behaves just as you have predicted.
It can target CD19 positive cells as well as
CD70 positive cells independently, whether
the target cells express one or both antigens.
Cell expansion generally tends to be better,
but that's in vitro. One thing I've learned over the years is what we
see in the in vitro, until we sort of see it in humans, that's really
hard to predict. The study's ongoing, and hopefully soon we'll be
able to answer that questions.
Okay. Thank you.
Katie, during your presentation, you
showed the differential
expansion of clone zero and clone four for
the early
period and the second for the
long-term persistence. And you mentioned that
different transcriptomic profile.
Can you elaborate a little bit more on the differences?
Yeah. The clone zero had transcription
factors much more supportive of effective function.
Clone four had
transcription factors that we tend to see with memory T cells or
stem cells like, for instance, TCF and KLF
and those ones. So that's why we really do think that
these clones are very different, and it isn't just
persistence of the adoptively infused
clones from the infusion product.
It's actually emergence of a new clone of
cells. But we find this very interesting, and of course, we're digging deeper into
that with the idea that once we find out those
transcription factors or genes that are dictating this persistence, we
can go back and then engineer these
memory-like NK cells.
David, there is a question from one of the people
connected online,
and it is: what's the impact of
anti-CD70 on viral immunity?
Do you anticipate issues with
anti-lymphoma factors as well? They are
indeed two.
Yeah. So, great question.
CD70
tends to get elevated whenever the T
cells are activated. So obviously, when
a body encounters virus, uh, and T cells start reacting,
they would express CD70. In
terms of what we see with CD70 is,
despite it being able to overcome the allorejection,
the cells do contract. I think there is a different biology going
on, not just a rejection and persistence, but
when CAR T does the work and when the antigen load
goes down, the CAR T cell simply
contracts. So the effect of CD70 is not going to be long-lasting.
Thank you. Please.
Yeah. So I'm glad you are talking about the CD70 CAR.
So I guess my follow-up question is, so do you think the
partial effect of the CD70 CAR expressing on the allo
T cell is because the CAR actually blocking the CD70 on the same
allo T cell, kind of preventing their rejection?
So
we don't
think so.
Because that's really coming from some of the
alloreactivity assays that's done, which gives more clarity
about
what's rejecting and how the rejection is
circumvented by eliminating the alloreactive T cells.
Mm-hmm.
CD70, there is also different biology.
Because CD70 is expressed, there is a fratricide issue that needs to
be addressed.
With a product that we have taken into the clinics, we address the
CD70 by so-called a cis-masking approach using the antibody
technology rather than editing out CD70 gene.
Yeah. So my follow-up question is more general in terms of using
allo T cells instead of NK. So how can you keep the
consistency, basically, if you're taking different batch of these allo T cells
to manufacture?
In terms of quality control, in terms of putting into patient, for example,
maybe this time you're using from this donor, but next time using from different
donor.
Yeah. So,
it's true. Right now,
most of the allogeneic cell therapy approach is
donor dependent. And donor-to-donor variability is
something that's being addressed through the manufacturing as well as
product release testing.
Okay. So one last question. How do you feel like this iPS
derived allo T cells in terms of all these different
modifications some company put in there?
Kathy, do you want to take that?
I think actually you should talk to Dan Kaufman, who's sitting right
there. And he is the world leader in iPSC
allogeneic NK cells. So,
Dan, maybe you can wave over.
No, no, just right next to you. To your left.
No, the gentleman.
Okay. Yeah. Dan, sorry.
Yeah.
Okay.
We can move on with the last two questions, please.
So thank you very much for the very stimulating presentations.
I have one question to
who of you is willing to respond, is that having allogeneic cells should
enable to detect if an actual reshaping
of the immune microenvironment with the patient's own immune
cells is taking place while these cells act.
Can you comment on this? Have you looked into this and if actually
the patient's own immune cells help in this type of response that you have
been observing?
I don't think that there are, at the moment,
data to speculate on this particular issue.
For sure, the allogeneic T cells have the
advantage, as I mentioned it in one of my slide,
not to be jeopardizing their function
of the possible microenvironment
in the healthy donor. But to the best of my
knowledge, there are no in-depth
investigation.
Yeah. And if I may add, we've been looking on seeing whether NK cells
can activate some of the endogenous immune cells, and I
showed some of those data in the setting of glioblastoma.
But it appears that at least NK cells can recruit
T cells and modulate the immune cells, and we've seen this
in multiple different
settings. So there is something going on, but in terms of really
mechanistically, we're still looking deeper into it.
Okay. Thank you.
Last question.
Thank you.
Great talks. My question is to both Dr. Locatelli and Rezvani.
I was wondering regarding allogeneic NK cell therapy or
allogeneic CAR-NK.
In your opinion,
for which indication it's more likely that we will see more
clinical efficacies in larger cohorts?
And I believe this could be also different depending on whether it's pediatric or
adult.
So let me start with the answer
that
we have, in a certain way, developed
at our hospital, namely that of investing
on AML because of the
consideration that were made before,
namely the need of obtaining
a clearance of leukemia blasts for then
proceeding with a consolidation allograft.
But the data that Kathy has presented clearly
demonstrated that the approach has the
potential to work also in other hematological
malignancies and in solid tumors.
The question is that, for example, we invested
on peripheral blood
NK cells and not on
cord blood cells. With our approach, we have been able to
generate from a single leukapheresis
an amount of aliquots sufficient
for around 200, 250 infusions.
Yes, and I agree. Obviously, hematologic
lymphoid malignancies seem to be
much more
sensitive in terms of both B cell malignancies, Hodgkin
lymphoma, T cell malignancies, we're getting very nice responses.
AML is certainly an area we're very interested in and we've
started. I think the problem with AML is the tumor
microenvironment is actually very similar to that of solid tumors, which is
why we introduced the TGF beta receptor
gene editing. And with solid
tumors, I think we just have to test in different settings,
perhaps in the setting of minimal residual disease, earlier in the disease
course, et cetera. We'll have to wait and see.
Thank you.
So once again, many thanks to my
great colleagues, and thanks to all of you for
attending this session. And enjoy the remaining
part of the meeting. Thank you.